esta escuela es una de varias en el
condado de cajeado que han publicado su
tamaño para ser refugios de niñas en
riesgo de mutilación genital femenina
grace fue sometida a la práctica con tan
sólo nueve años estos me tomaron
desprevenidas cuando me despertaron
tarde en la noche alrededor de las 2 de
la mañana ordenaron desnudarme y me
mutilaron a la fuerza con la viuda una
de cada cinco niñas en el país es
víctima de la mutilación genital
femenina en este centro educativo el 90%
tiene entre 12 y 16 años la escuela
trabaja con las autoridades locales para
proteger a las niñas y hacerles saber
sus derechos
las chicas conocen sus derechos ahora
por lo que pueden escapar han de morir
saben no tengo que ir con ellos ejemplo
de que andan y las tasas de prevalencia
nacionales han disminuido del 38 al 21
por ciento en las últimas dos décadas la
costumbre fue declarada ilegal en 2011
pero algunos continúan practicando la de
forma encubierta
esta ong intensificó sus campañas de
sensibilización tras un repunte durante
la pandemia de kobe 19
el mayor desafío es que la mutilación
genital femenina es una ceremonia
tradicional escultural ancha es de la
cancha sacar eso del núcleo de su
cultura no es fácil a paso no es no es
de las personas que a través de esta
práctica se ganan la vida reciben
aproximadamente 15 euros por corte
algunos han encontrado fuentes
alternativas de ingresos como la
fabricación de cuentas y tapetes esta
mujer que realizaba la práctica dice que
su comunidad se ha alejado de la
costumbre todos los padres y tutores
acordaron no circuncidar a sus hijas por
lo que las preocupaciones al respecto
están disminuyendo las niñas ahora
pueden estar más tranquilas al volver a
casa de la escuela a pesar de la
predicción del presidente keniata de que
la práctica terminaría en 2022 las ong
dicen que puede llevar muchos años más
eliminarla por completo